are you proposing that the entire world
limit having sex to just when women are
ovulating no when they're not unless
they want to have a baby what would be
the reason for that other than just for
protection well you wouldn't have to be
on birth control you would now as a
woman track your cycle more men would
too will we'd be invested yes you'd
understand we'd have to it would be an
interesting
an interesting experiment to try and run
but when people want it they want it you
know and especially given the fact that
women sex drive women's desire for more
masculine men women's desire for more
dominance in men for men with more
masculinized faces all of this stuff
increases precisely during the time when
you're telling them to not have sex like
the person that gets damaged the most by
this philosophy by your tyrannical new
sex policy
is the the people that are going to be
the most damaged by this are the women
because when Sex Drive is highest you're
going to say let's try and let's try and
push this down